parents all of us were quick to be like
oh this sucks i think it's awesome i
think a lot of kids have friends on the
internet that aren't naturally in their
high school what happened if you were in
a school that you got bullied and it
wasn't nice and you had no friends but
now you can go on twitch and play video
games with the people that have your
interests you have an outlet we were all
stuck with if it wasn't working at
school for you you were [ __ ] it's not
over it [ __ ] sucks people are
choosing to look at the downside of
social today i see the upside we've
always judged the next generation's
version of how they communicate people
think their kids are less social they're
more social a lot of people have friend
networks around their interests that
aren't there 25 years ago because they
didn't have that and they were just
stuck as being the weird kid that like
comic books like [ __ ] look at me like
brandon warnicky scott hunter big shout
out to you guys only two kids that want
to talk about business in high school
with me like today i'd be [ __ ]
killing it on the talk linkedin yeah